[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend das
neue Jahr beginnt hier zu Lande mit
einer Diskussion über böllerverbote eine
neue Debatte ist das ja nicht die
entsprechenden Argumente dafür und
dagegen sind hinlänglich bekannt was in
der Diskussion vielleicht etwas
untergeht ist dass die Übergriffe auf
feuerwehr und Rettungskräfte schon seit
Jahren auch jenseits von
silvesternächten zugenommen haben
diesmal war es allerdings besonders
heftig sagen Einsatzkräfte in Teilen
Berlins etwa wurde regelrecht Krieg
gespielt henrigierte
Aufnahmen aus einem Fahrzeug der
Berliner Feuerwehr aus der
Silvesternacht von vorn werden die
Einsatzkräfte mit Pyrotechnik beschossen
die Besatzung alarmiert per Funk die
Polizei versucht es zunächst mit einer
Ansprache
doch der Appell ist vergeblich es bleibt
nur der Rückzug
so wir fahren rückwärts wie heftig die
Attacken waren zeigt ein weiteres Video
ein Feuerlöscher wird auf einen
Rettungswagen geworfen glücklicherweise
hielt die Windschutzscheibe stand über
100 Festnahmen verzeichnete die Berliner
Polizei in der Silvesternacht
überwiegend junge Männer die Feuerwehr
Gewerkschaft spricht von Gewalt wie es
sie zum Jahreswechsel noch nie gegeben
hat die Qualität ist also so da dass die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wirklich Angst
hatten Angst um ihr Leben hatten das
muss ich vorstellen wenn sie von innen
sitzen als als erwachsener Mann und
versuchen die Türen zuzuhalten damit
keiner reinkommt und draußen stehen
Leute die schmeißen Steine drängen mit
Eisenstangen auf einen ein das ist schon
außergewöhnlich der Attacken
beschäftigen längst nicht mehr nur die
Berliner Lokalpolitik zum alles auch in
anderen deutschen Städten zu Übergriffen
kam die bundesinnenministerin kündigt an
dass die Täter Hintergründe nun genau
untersucht würden und fordert eine
konsequente Bestrafung Gott sei Dank
sind die Strafvorschriften
meine Taten gegen rettungs- und
Einsatzkräfte verschärft worden und ich
finde zu Recht in den letzten Jahren
aber das muss jetzt auch angewandt
werden weil die Täterinnen und Täter
auch merken müssen dass das
ernstzunehmende Konsequenzen hat was die
Täter antreibt darüber wird nun
ebenfalls diskutiert Nervenkitzel Kräfte
messen von Halbstarken Langeweile
Psychologen jeden weiter sie glauben
dass viele von ihnen den Respekt vor dem
Staat und seinen Vertretern verloren
haben
in vermutlich Menschen und Teile
Bevölkerung die sich ausgeschlossen
fühlen die der Politik sehr distanziert
gegenüberstehen und das kann auf Dauer
nicht nur weil Gewalt gegen
Rettungskräfte die Polizei und Feuerwehr
Problem werden sondern ganz insgesamt
kann das unseren gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt gefährden für die Polizei
Gewerkschaft geht es zunächst darum die
Silvester Exzesse künftig zu verhindern
die Vorschläge sein längst diskutiert
bis heute aber nicht umgesetzt es gab
keinen generelles böllerverbot es ist
Aufgabe des Bundesministerium für
inneren hier das Sprengstoffgesetz zu
novellieren anzupacken das ist nicht
geschehen und die Länder insbesondere
Kommunen haben sich mit Verbotszonen
beholfen die mal besser mal schlechter
gewirkt haben Gewalt gegen Einsatzkräfte
ist kein Problem das nur an Silvester
besteht die Neujahrsnacht hat aber
wieder einmal gezeigt wie dringlich der
Handlungsbedarf ist
zu dem Thema gibt es nachher im heute
journal Update noch ein Gespräch mit dem
Präsidenten des deutschen
Feuerwehrverbandes Karl-heinz Banse
für Menschen aus der Ukraine die vor den
Explosionen echter Raketen geflüchtet
sind und diese furchterregenden
Geräusche noch traumatischem Ohr haben
weil die Silvesternacht in Deutschland
eh eine Prüfung zu wissen dass die
Heimat gerade unter einem Raketenhagel
steht während um einen herum aus Spaß
geknallt wird es waren zwei schlimme
Tage und Nächte für die Ukraine
insbesondere Kiew wurde von Russland
massiv angegriffen aber die Ukrainer
wären sich auch die Russen hatten in der
Neujahrsnacht schwere Verluste Christian
von Rechenberg Bericht
es sollen Bilder aus mariew gar sein
Ostukraine russisch besetztes Gebiet
angeblich nach einem Angriff durch die
Ukraine
vier Raketen mit hochexplosiven
Sprengköpfen sind in einer
militärunterkunft eingeschlagen das
Ergebnis 63 getötete russische Soldaten
die Ukraine hat sich zu dem Angriff
bekannt meldet ihrerseits Attacken durch
Drohnen rund 40 alle abgeschossen doch
selbst die Trümmerteile sind
lebensgefährlich dieses Haus in Kiew hat
einiges abbekommen
in der Nacht hörte ich einen riesen
Knall die Möbel wackelten da ist schon
Luft Alarm gegeben hatte war ja klar was
passiert war
nur ein verletzter junge hier bei
anderen Angriffen starben seit Silvester
mindestens fünf Menschen
wir sind stark der Feind ist schwach so
die Botschaft des Präsidenten man kann
ihre Angst spüren und sie haben allen
Grundangst zu haben weil sie verlieren
werden
da hilft nur Propaganda zu besichtigen
in einer bizarren neujahrsendung des
russischen Fernsehens wo ein feucht
fröhlicher gute Laune Onkel Russland
zunächst zur tragenden Säule der Welt
erklärt und dann setzt da noch einen
drauf
ja liebe Leute finden Sie sich damit ab
Russland wächst
und während sie im Studio ihre
Verbrechen feiern schlagen ihre Raketen
in Kiefer ein Anatoli verliert seine
Schwiegertochter sein Haus um ein Haar
sein Leben trotz Rippenbrüchen trotz
Schnittwunden sucht danach
Habseligkeiten
nichts anderes meine Schwiegertochter es
tut mir so leid
die Schwiegertochter sie war gerade in
der Küche da na tolli mit seinem
Enkelkind nebenan er hatte Glück ein
Trost ist das trotzdem nicht sie müssen
trauern und durchhalten fertig werden
mit einem Krieg mit dem auch die
Verteidigungsministerin konfrontiert ist
vor Weihnachten stellt sie der Slowakei
weitere Luftabwehr in Aussicht und
bezieht sich dann auch in einem
neujahrsvideo auf den Krieg aufgenommen
unter denkbar unglücklichen Bedingungen
unglaubliche Herausforderung gestellt
mitten in Europa Tod eintreten und damit
verbunden waren für mich ganz viele
besondere Eindrücke die ich gewinnen
konnte viele viele
interessanten und tollen Menschen dafür
sagt ich habe die Kritik kommt
postwendend Sport und Häme im Netz und
tragbar sei sie das neue Jahr beginnt
für Christine Lambrecht alles andere als
gut
in Berlin in der medialen Öffentlichkeit
viel Kopfschütteln über dieses Video
aber aus der Ampelkoalition hört man
dazu nicht viel ja nach Unterstützung
aus den eigenen Reihen brauchte sich die
Ministerin heute nicht umzuschauen die
gab es nämlich so nicht ihr eigenes
Ministerium ließ auf Anfrage nur wissen
das sei ein privat aufgenommenes Video
und das Kanzleramt wollte sich zu dem
ganzen Vorfall gleich gar nicht äußern
wollte das nicht kommentieren und das
obwohl der Bundeskanzler ja kurz vor
Weihnachten noch ähm Christine Lambrecht
in einem Zeitungsinterview als
erstklassige Ministerin bezeichnet hat
und dort in dem Interview auch sagte
über manche Kritik an ihr könnte man
sich eigentlich nur wundern eine
vergleichbare Verteidigung gab es heute
weder von den Koalitionspartnern noch
aus der SPD es gab überhaupt nur eine
prominente Stimme aus der Ampel die sich
zu Wort gemeldet hat das war die FDP
verteidigungspolitikerin Marie Agnes
stark Zimmermann und die sagte nur das
Setting sei etwas unglücklich aus ihrer
Sicht
die öffentliche Erregung wäre vermutlich
auch weniger groß würde die Ministerin
nicht eh schon mit Amtsführung und
Kommunikation in der Kritik stehen ja
das Verteidigungsministerium ist ja
traditionell ein Posten der auch als
Schleudersitz als politischer
Schleudersitz bezeichnet wird deswegen
ist Kritik an einer
Verteidigungsministerin auch nicht
ungewöhnlich aber bei Christine
Lamprecht kommt da schon einiges
zusammen kritiker werfen ihr vor bei der
Bundeswehr nicht entschieden genug und
nicht schnell genug zu handeln sie sei
zu langsam bei der Beseitigung von
Mängeln in der Bundeswehr in der
Bundeswehr Ausstattung sie sei nicht
entschlossen genug weil Strukturreformen
die sie angekündigt hat jetzt aber nicht
durchführen möchte und dazu kommt eben
auch noch die Kommunikation die bei ihr
offensichtlich wirklich ein Problem
fällt ist denn es ist nicht das erste
Mal dass sie durch ungeschickt ist
Handeln in der Öffentlichkeit oder
Auftreten in der Öffentlichkeit und
durch ungeschickt Kommunikation auffällt
man erinnert sich daran dass sie bei den
ersten Forderungen nach mobilitärischer
unterstütz für die Ukraine sehr stolz
5.000 Helme als Lieferung angekündigt
hat und dafür schon Sport bekommen hat
dass Bilder von ihrem Sohn in einem
Bundeswehr Helikopter bei einer
Dienstreise aufgetaucht sind in sozialen
Medien was nicht glücklich gewesen ist
und jetzt eben dieses Video das
dazugekommen ist da hat sie sich auf
jeden Fall selber keinen Gefallen getan
und sich bei der Liste derjenige die
hier laut in Frage gestellt werden im
Kabinett weiter nach vorne gearbeitet
Dankeschön nach Berlin
und mit Blick auf dem Krieg in der
Ukraine hat Nato-Generalsekretär Jens
Stoltenberg einen nachdrücklichen Appell
an die Mitgliedsländer gerichtet damit
beginnen die Nachrichten Hans
Stoltenberg hat gesagt man müsste sich
darauf einstellen die Ukraine
langfristig zu unterstützen aus Russland
habe es keine Anzeichen gegeben dass es
sein übergeordnetes Ziel einer Übernahme
der Ukraine aufgegeben habe so
Stoltenberg in einem Gespräch mit der
britischen BBC er mahnte eine Erhöhung
der Waffenproduktion in der westlichen
Militärallianz an Stoltenberg verwiesen
unter anderem darauf dass seine enorme
Menge an Munition und Ersatzteile
gebraucht würden
seit heute können Gläubige Abschied vom
emeritierten Papst nehmen der Leichnam
Benedikt des 16 wird bis Mittwoch
öffentlich im Petersdom aufgebahrt
die ersten Gläubigen standen bereits in
der Nacht Schlange für Donnerstag ist
ein Trauergottesdienst geplant
anschließend wird Benedikt in der Krypta
des Petersdoms beigesetzt dazu werden
mehr als 50.000 Menschen im Vatikan
erwartet
in Iran hat der Oberste Gerichtshof im
Zusammenhang mit den Protesten im Land
ein weiteres Todesurteil gegen einen
Demonstranten bestätigt laut einer
Justiz Internetseite wurde der junge
Mann verurteilt weil er
Sicherheitskräfte mit einer Waffe
verletzt haben soll bislang wurden
bereits zwei Demonstranten hingerichtet
und nach iranischen Presseberichten
stehen über 20 weitere Demonstranten auf
der Todesliste der Justiz
nachdem die EU in der vergangenen Woche
noch keine gemeinsame Linie zur
corona-welle in China beschlossen hatte
soll nun übermorgen ein einheitliches
Vorgehen beraten werden das teilte die
schwedische EU-Ratspräsidentschaft mit
dabei geht es vor allem um die Frage wie
mit Einreisenden aus China umgegangen
werden soll Frankreich Italien und
Spanien haben bereits Beschränkungen
beschlossen
in Lutzerath im rheinischen Braunkohle
Revier haben Vorbereitungen zur Räumung
des Dorfes begonnen es soll einem
Tagebau weichen klimaaktivisten
versuchten am Vormittag Polizisten am
Betreten von Lutzerath zu hindern dabei
kam es zu Handgemengen und
flaschenwürfen für Mitte Januar ist die
Räumung von Lutzerath geplant die dort
abgebaute Kohle soll nach Angaben des
Energiekonzerns RWE helfen die sichere
Versorgung von Kraftwerken zu
gewährleisten
in Brasilien haben tausende pele-fans
der Fußball-Legende die letzte Ehre
erwiesen der Sarg wurde per Autokorso
etwa 80 km von Sao Paulo nach Santos
gebracht im Stadion der Stadt wird der
Leichnam des dreimaligen Weltmeisters 24
Stunden aufgebaut wir lieber am
vergangenen Donnerstag im Alter von 82
Jahren nach langer Krankheit gestorben
die Trauer um ihrer Ikone Pelé trifft
die Brasilianer in einer Zeit in der es
ihrem Land eh nicht gut geht die
wirtschaftliche Lage ist übel die
Gesellschaft tiefgespalten nach den
bolzenario Jahren die ähnlich
polarisierend wirkten wie die Trump
Jahre Nordamerika
mittlerweile in die USA abgesetzt nun
liegen alle Hoffnungen auf einem alten
Bekannten Luna das Silva hat heute sein
Amt angetreten zum dritten Mal steht er
als Präsident an der Spitze des Landes
in einer denkbar schwierigen
Ausgangslage Christoph
Eileen zusa lebt sonst davon Müll
aufzusammeln doch nun übergibt Sie Luis
inaselula das Silva die
präsidentenschärfe gemeinsam mit anderen
Vertretern jener Menschen die aus Sicht
der neuen Regierung in den letzten
Jahren missachtet wurden darunter
Arbeiter Frauen Kinder schwarze indigene
Menschen mit Behinderung sie alle
vereint mit dem neuen Präsidenten ein
emotionaler Moment einzigartig in der
Geschichte Brasiliens
der eigentlich für die Übergabe
zuständige Amtsvorgänger Holze naro
hatte sich kurzfristig in die USA
abgesetzt dessen von politischer
Spaltung geprägte Ära will Lula hinter
sich lassen
mit unseren Familien und Freunden
nachdem diese zerrissen wurden von all
der Hetze und den Lügen Schluss mit Hass
Fake News Waffen und Bomben
diese Demokratie feindliche Saat
bolzenarus ist zum Teil aber bereits
aufgegangen viele seiner Anhänger
verweigern die Realität des knappen
Wahlergebnisses wochenlang demonstrieren
sie vor Kasernen und fordern einen
Militärputsch
auch an sie dürfte Lula denken am Tag
seines Triumphes an seiner Fähigkeit das
gespaltene Land zu versöhnen wird er
sich messen lassen müssen
sein zentrales Versprechen ist mehr
soziale Gerechtigkeit seine Stimme
bricht als er dem zunehmenden Hunger im
Land den Kampf ansagt viele
Menschen Wühlen in Metzgerei Abfällen
weil sie hungern
gleichzeitig warten andere auf
importierte Autos und Privatjets
so eine soziale Kluft steht einer
gerechten demokratischen Gesellschaft im
Weg
wird
sein Kabinett ist größer und diverser
als zuvor auch beim Umweltschutz
verspricht Lula eine radikale Kehrtwende
und so reicht auch Europa Brasilien
wieder die Hand Bundespräsident
Steinmeier gratuliert als einer der
ersten und reißt dann weiter als
Amazonasgebiet dort besucht er ein
Deutsch brasilianisches
Forschungsprojekt dass ich mit den
Wechselwirkungen zwischen Regenwald und
Klima befasst
unter den vielen Vorhaben die wir uns
für das neue Jahr gemacht haben gehört
Klimaschutz und der Schutz der
Regenwälder ganz oben auf die
Tagesordnung und da sollte er auch nicht
herunterrutschen unter bolzenario gab es
vier Jahre lang Kahlschlag im Regenwald
und auf diplomatischer Ebene nun setzen
Europa und Brasilien auf einen Neuanfang
füreinander und fürs Weltklima
zurück nach Deutschland mit dem neuen
Jahr soll auch eine neue Zeitrechnung in
der Sozialpolitik beginnen Hartz IV wird
abgelöst durch das neue Bürgergeld vor
allem die SPD hofft damit ihr Herz
Trauma zu überwinden und dass der
ungeliebte Begriff recht bald aus dem
allgemeinen Wortschatz verschwindet das
Bürgergeld besser klingt als Herzen dem
werden die meisten wohl zustimmen aber
die inhaltlichen Fragen bleiben ja wie
Arbeitslose besser vermittelt werden
können und welche Sozialleistungen
angemessen sind was ich da jetzt ändert
erläutert an seinem Sterben
der Alltag im neuen Jahr beginnt in
Deutschland Jobcentern mit neuen Regeln
mit neuen Regeln Hartz IV ist Geschichte
aus Hartz IV Empfängern werden
Bürgergeld Empfänger für las Lolli
hotski ist die wichtigste Nachricht es
gibt zumindest ein wenig mehr Geld
das ist dringend notwendig das finde ich
das wichtige finde ich sehr schön
natürlich weil ich dann einfach wirklich
besser leben kann Freude über eine
kleine Steigerung in Zeiten in denen so
vieles immer mehr kostet Bürgergeld
heißt 53 Euro mehr als früher
alleinstehende bekommen jetzt also 500 2
Euro pro Monat plus Wohnkosten
die Menschen freuen sich natürlich über
das Meer an an Geld aber es ist
tatsächlich auch so dass man in Sorge
ist weil die Lebenshaltungskosten immer
noch steigen die Energiekosten steigen
noch gut die Heizungskosten die werden
im angeben angemessene Höhe vom
Jobcenter getragen die Stromkosten das
kann dann noch mal eine Herausforderung
werden eine Herausforderung wird das
Bürgergeld für die Jobcenter im Sommer
dann müssen die Mitarbeiter neue Regeln
bei der Jobvermittlung kennen und
umsetzen mehr Angebote mehr Geld für
Weiterbildung Berufsabschlüsse und
Existenzgründungen sollen dann
Arbeitslose in langfristige Arbeit
bringen wir haben auch spezielle
Angebote dass man da nach einer
Qualifizierung auch noch meine
Unterstützung bekommen und Coaching das
wird auf jeden Fall auch nachhaltig
helfen das neue Bürgergeld bringt ganz
viel positive Effekte mit für die Kunden
und Kunden insbesondere im Hinblick auf
die berufliche Bildung und die
nachhaltige Integration in Arbeit und
wir haben in Deutschland einen
Fachkräftemangel von daher finde ich die
neuen Förderleistungen und insbesondere
das Weiterbildungsgeld ganz besonders
gut ganz besonders umstritten war und
ist das Bürgergeld politisch das Fördern
stärken oder das fordern Alter
hartz-iv-streit der weitergeht fest
steht wer als Empfänger etwa nicht zu
Terminen erscheint dem drohen weiterhin
Sanktionen wir werden sehen ob sich
durch das Bürgergeld wirklich was
verbessert die Menschen kriegen erstmal
ein bisschen mehr Geld aber das wird
nicht reichen bei den derzeitigen
Preisentwicklungen aber ob sich wirklich
was verbessert und mehr Menschen in
Arbeit kommen durch Qualifikation und
Weiterbildung das sollte die
Bundesregierung dringend evaluieren noch
offen also die Frage wie groß die große
Sozialreform der ampelregierung wirklich
sein kann für die neuen
bürgergeld-empfänger bedeutet sie ab
sofort erst einmal ein klein wenig mehr
Geld im schwierigen Alltag
mit wirtschaftlichen Aussichten geht es
jetzt auch bei dir noch mal weiter Heinz
da schauen wir auf den Immobilienmarkt
denn es könnte sich nach Einschätzung
von Experten eine Entwicklung abzeichnen
die heißt Kaufpreise sinken Mieten
steigen Stefanie berrett das heißt das
konkret wer muss dann nun womit rechnen
naja neben der ohnehin schon bekannten
Knappheit auf dem Wohnungsmarkt wächst
jetzt offenbar auch der Druck bei den
Mieten denn mit steigenden Kreditzinsen
und hohen Baukosten Platz für viele
Menschen gerade der Traum von der
eigenen Immobilie und sie weichen wieder
verstärkt auf Mietwohnungen aus das
treibt die Preise mit einem Plus von
5,8% gegenüber dem Vorjahr ziehen die
Mieten wieder deutlich stärker an als in
den Jahren zuvor Vermieter legen ihre
höheren finanzierungs- und
Materialkosten auf die Mieten um zudem
sinken die lehrstände besonders in den
Städten was den Druck auf den Markt
zusätzlich erhöht Wohnungen dürften auch
in Zukunft knapp bleiben denn seit
Monaten schon lässt eine Welle
stornierter Wohnungsbauprojekte die
Neubau bezahlen auch für
mietbauwohnungen einbrechen vom
ehrgeizigen Ziel 400.000 neue Wohnungen
pro Jahr zu bauen ist die
Bundesregierung meilenweit entfernt der
Zentralverband des Deutschen Baugewerbes
rechnet in diesem Jahr gerade noch mit
245.9 Wohnungen überraschend dynamisch
startet hier heute der DAX ins neue Jahr
gut ein Prozent gewinnt das
Börsenbarometer und überspringt wieder
die Marke von 14.000 Punkten mal sehen
wie stabil dieser Jahresauftakt vor dem
Hintergrund der Krisen ist an vielen
Börsen dieser Welt beginnt ja erst
morgen der Handel Stephan vielen Dank
im bayerischen Ruhpolding haben die
ersten Winter Games des jüdischen
Sportverbandes makabi Deutschland
begonnen die Winterspiele mit Sportarten
von Ski Alpin bis snow Volleyball dauern
bis zum 9 Januar
sie sind aus aller Welt ins bayerische
Ruhpolding gekommen jüdische
Sportlerinnen und Sportler feiern
gemeinsam die Eröffnung der makabi
Winterspiele die ersten in Deutschland
die ersten seit 87 Jahren
Traditionen etwas das vor dem Weltkrieg
sehr aktiv war wird jetzt wiederbelebt
die letzten makabi Winterspiele fanden
1936 in der ehemaligen Tschechoslowakei
statt damals nahmen 2000 Athleten aus 12
Nationen teil nach Ruhpolding sind etwa
400 Sportlerinnen und Sportler gekommen
natürlich geht es auch hier um den
Wettkampf aber auch darum Vorurteile ab
und Brücken aufzubauen
Deutschland ist heutzutage ein freies
und demokratisches Land und freut sich
darüber dass endlich mal die das
jüdische Leben auch in diesem Bereich
sichtbar ist was er in den früheren
Zeiten nicht der Fall war mit den
jüdischen Winterspielen in Deutschland
wird eine Tradition wiederbelebt und
zugleich ein Zeichen gesetzt gegen
Rassismus und Antisemitismus
manche Jahreszahlen eignen sich
besonders für historische Rückblicke 23
ist auch so eine Zahl da werden sich in
diesem Jahr einen Buchläden viele Titel
finden die sich mit 1923 beschäftigen
einem deutschen Krisenjahr in dem die
junge Weimarer Republik in mehrfacher
Hinsicht unter Druck geriet Andreas
Weise blickt zurück auf das 23 vor 100
Jahren
es sind vor allem diese Scheine mit den
Unsummen darauf die heute noch erinnern
an 1923 ein Schicksalsjahr der deutschen
doch das war nicht das einzige das den
Menschen vor 100 Jahren zu schaffen
machte der Historiker mag Jones hat sich
eingehend mit diesem Jahr und was es
heute noch für uns bedeutet
auseinandergesetzt es war eine Zeit
beschleunigte Krisen also die Krisen es
gab eine Kette von Krisen eine Spirale
von Krisen die waren alle miteinander
verbunden und die sind Dirk des Jahrgang
dann durch das Jahr beschleunigt gleich
im Januar französische und belgische
Truppen besetzen das Ruhrgebiet sie
wollen mehr Reparationen nach dem
Weltkrieg der große Teile ihrer Länder
verwüstet hatte
passiver Widerstand der Bevölkerung
gegen die Besetzung Streik finanziell
unterstützt durch die Reichsregierung
die dann aber im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes die Gelddruckmaschinen anwerfen
muss Ergebnis eine Hyperinflation die
keiner spartes übrig lässt Georg von
Wallwitz hat ein Buch über das Trauma
der Inflation geschrieben und warum es
bis heute die deutsche Finanzpolitik
prägt im Ersten Weltkrieg und in der
Zeit unmittelbar danach war nämlich die
Reichsbank die damals die Notenbank war
war
eine Abteilung im Finanzministerium also
sozusagen weisungsgebunden gegenüber dem
Finanzminister und das ist ein Zustand
den man eben
verhindern wollte für die Zukunft und
deswegen sieht eben unsere Bundesbank
heute so aus wie sie aussieht und Ihr
Kind die die EZB die Europäische
Zentralbank sieht auch so aus also
Unabhängigkeit und oberste Maxime ist
Geld wird Stabilität im November 1923
stoppt die Reichsregierung unter Kanzler
Stresemann die Inflation mit Hilfe der
sogenannten Rentenmark Umtausch kurz zur
Reichsmark 1 zu einer Billionen doch das
Elend in weiten Teilen der Bevölkerung
kann so auch nicht schnell gestoppt
werden ich glaube es ist sehr wichtig zu
betonen dass dieses Jahr war kein Jahr
des goldenen 20er Jahren es war ein Jahr
von Elend es gab medizinischen Studien
zu der Zeitpunkt die gezeigt haben dass
die deutschen Kinder in diesem Jahr
aufgehört haben zu wachsen sie wachsen
nicht nur nicht nicht mehr normal weil
es fehlten das Essen und auch politisch
brennt es an vielen Ecken fünf Jahre
nach der Ausrufung der Republik hat
Deutschland wenig Demokraten
kommunistische Aufstände in Sachsen und
Thüringen werden niedergeschlagen
und dann wollen die Nazis unter Adolf
Hitler am 8 und 9 November von München
aus nach der Macht greifen es missling
kläglich diesmal das Ende des Jahres
1923 sieht die deutsche Demokratie sogar
gestärkt doch auf Dauer nicht stark
genug auch weil Hass Hetze und
Propaganda weiter blühen das Problem von
missinformation ist in Köln Problem der
politischen Geschichte der Weimarer
Republik und wer die Demokratie von
heute starken will kann vieles lernen
aus der Geschichte der missinformationen
in der Weimarer Zeit wie Lügen und zum
Wahrheiten würden war ein Problem damals
ist es ein Problem heute
1923 ein Schicksalsjahr der deutschen
das immer noch nachwirkt
und da wir gerade schon bei einem Blick
zurück sind heute vor 45 Jahren am
zweiten Januar 1978 ging das erste heute
journal auf Sendung damals mit Dieter
Kron Zucker der gleich mit der ihm
eigenen Nonchalance ein Akzent setzte
[Musik]
also wir begrüßen Sie zum heute journal
ein kleines Jubiläum also für uns heute
viereinhalb Jahrzehnte fernsehtradition
und wir haben uns erweitert mit dem
heute schon mal Update das gibt es heute
um 23:40 Uhr mit Gundula Gause
[Musik]
einen wunderschönen guten Abend ja die
Kaltfront von tiefen Magdalena schleift
jetzt noch etwas an den Alpen dann sorgt
aber ein Zwischenhoch morgen für einen
meist ruhigen Tag bevor in der Nacht auf
Mittwoch diese Tiefs auf uns übergreifen
diese Atlantik tief sorgen jetzt auch
dafür dass es in dieser Woche etwas
kühler wird als noch zuletzt nach diesem
irrsinnig milden Jahreswechsel aber es
bleibt immer noch zu mild für diese
Jahreszeit immerhin die Winterkälte hat
sich jetzt hier in Sibirien angesammelt
und rückt uns damit etwas mehr in der
Nacht meist einstellige Werte zwischen
zwei und acht Grad dazu eben mit der
Kaltfront etwas Regen an den Alpen der
Wind lässt nach er wird nur noch an den
küstenlebhaft und wir haben viele Wolken
und einige Schauer noch über der Mitte
des Landes die Reste dieser Schauer gibt
es auch noch am Vormittag zwischen dem
Alge und dem Berchtesgadener Land gibt
es auch weiter etwas Regen der dann
nachmittags aber größtenteils nachlässt
dafür kommen von Nordwesten neue Wolken
die spätestens am Abend dann auch Regen
bringen die Temperaturen liegen zwischen
sechs Grad an der Ostsee und 12 Grad am
Oberrhein und das ist auch das
Temperaturniveau mit dem es in der
nächsten Woche weitergeht bevor es dann
am Mittwoch wieder stürmisch wird und
vor allem im Norden zum Beispiel in
Schleswig-Holstein
mecklenburg-Vorpommern und Niedersachsen
richtig regnerisch das war es von uns
tschüss